- If somebody goes to a
restaurant for the first time
and has a flawless experience,
the statistical likelihood of them
doing a second visit is about 40 percent.
They come back
- [Caller] Yeah,
I believe that too
- the second time
- [Caller] yeah
- And have a flawless experience,
the statistical likelihood
of a third visit
is still about 42 percent.
The third time they come,
the statistical likelihood
of a fourth visit
is over 70 percent.
So,
- [Caller] wow.
- You gotta mark it to
three visits, not one.
Visit one free rib dinner
- [Caller] wow.
You sit 'em down,
- [Caller] yeah.
- Put a red napkin on the
table, not a white one.
Identify them as a first time customer,
connect with them, and
work to get 'em back
a second time and a third time.
Once they're there the third time,
you own 'em.
- My man Chandler
- [Caller] Oh, the red napkin
thing is genuis, 'cause in
the fast casual environment
we're not hitting that table side, but
- Let me give you
- [Caller] 'cause it's
- Chandler,
- can I detail that for him?
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- Okay, so you put a
red napkin at the table.
Gary sits down, he's eating dinner,
now he's getting his free rib dinner,
his water costs him nothing.
I know he's a first time customer,
'cause he's got a red napkin.
When he's leaving, and the
manager comes to the table,
writes on the back of a business card,
five dollars off chicken.
"Did you like the ribs?"
"loved 'em"
"you gotta try my chicken,
come in for the chicken"
now I'm prompting a second visit.
Not with a printed coupon,
but a hand-written card.
Now he comes in for the second visit,
drops the business card on the table,
everybody knows this is the second visit,
'cause red napkin was the first visit.
Second visit, you finish the meal,
you go up, you say,
"so how was the chicken?"
"it was frickin' great!"
"are you full?"
"totally stuffed"
"man, next time you
gotta try my cheesecake"
free piece of cheesecake.
Now, three visits, ribs
- wait, a pizza?
- [Chandler] A piece of cheesecake.
- Oh, a pizza flavored cheesecake,
I was like "that's f___ brilliant"
- So the rib dinner costs me five dollars.
The chicken was a wash out,
'cause it was a discount,
- That's right.
- The cheesecake was $1.35.
For about six dollars, you
got three visits out of him
with a 70 percent likelihood of a fourth.
That's the way you mark at a restaurant,
within four walls of it.
- [Caller] That is huge right there.
- Chandler
- [Caller] That's why you are the best.
- Chandler, let me give you, listen.
Let me give you one more
for the road, mister.
There was a very interesting
thing that John said.
Because I grew up in that environment too,
and John's from the
traditional marketing world
that we grew up in,
pulling from his world.
Notice how he said, first time customer,
I'll give it to you.
Because the traditional
retail and bar thing
is like, look, it's more expensive,
if you've already got
somebody in the funnel,
the cost of acquisition for a new buddy
is very very very powerful.
I used to do that too,
but it was tricky, right?
Because now some of
your old time customers
may see that, and they've got that angst
of "wait a minute, why am I
being not treated that way,
as a loyal customer, you
just want new people"
and it's always been a
friction for us, right?
Now, I just went to Instagram, right?
I typed in Lexington, Kentucky.
Got it?
- [Caller] Yessir.
- I'm looking at nine posts right now,
that are top posts,
and ungodly amounts, unlimited
amounts of people's posts
that are from Lexington, Kentucky,
I went all the way down, and
that's from 48 minutes ago.
40 pictures down, 48 minutes ago.
Thousands of people are
posting right now on Instagram
from Lexington, Kentucky.
I go to the top nine posts.
I click the middle one, it's
a nice little cute couple.
They got 298 likes.
Abby, she's got, she's from somewhere,
she's part of a sorority it looks like.
She has 2,387 followers.
There's a triple dot in the
top right corner on Instagram.
I hit it, it lets me send her a message.
I send her a message, "Abby,
see you're in Lexington.
We love being part of Lexington.
Here's a 20 dollar off
coupon, 10 dollar off coupon,
free chicken", only she sees it.
You're grabbing somebody who
has a big social media profile.
You've not hurt any of
your loyal customers
like me and John had to back in the day,
she comes, and she posts
a picture of the food,
and creates word of mouth.
Now that five dollar acquisition
created no friction to loyal customers,
and because she's now media,
she amplifies it, and you're
getting an 80, 500, 4000 dollar
media amplification, against
your five f_____ dollars!
- And last one thing, don't discount.
People get addicted to discounts,
the don't get addicted to free.
- [Gary] That's right.
(jazz music)